- I am going into this
a tad bit concerned.
But we have a great, you
know, research department
and I'm sure they wouldn't put me in
any real danger, right, right?
Maybe, I don't know.
(upbeat music)
- We're doing a soup cleanse! (laughs)
- Apparently it's healthy.
I'm not sure, I've heard
questionable things
about cleanses.
- One other time in my life I attempted
to do a juice cleanse,
key word being attempted because
I quit after day two.
- I don't even like soup that much.
Everyone else loves soup.
I'm not the biggest souphead.
- Hey, I'm the world's biggest soup fan,
that's what I'm trying to say here.
I'm just a soup guy.
- I don't know, 'cause
I like testing myself.
- A soup cleanse is different than any
other kind of liquid cleanse
that you might have because
we make sure that we
have all the nutrition
that your body needs in a day.
- So the soup arrives in
this giant bag and there
is a lot of soup.
- This is so heavy, this is like a baby.
- This is gonna be inside
me by the end of the day
and I'm straining to hold this.
As with anything new, the first day
wasn't the worst.
- I am eating the chicken broth soup
for the first time.
That's actually like really good.
- There were a lot more soups
than I thought there'd be, a wide variety.
(laughter)
- I thought the soups were amazing.
They were the best part
of the whole experience.
Today's the end of day one.
For the most part, the
day was pretty good.
- Definitely the worst and hardest part
of all of this was going out to eat
with other people who were eating
delicious food.
They're eating these delicious salads
and I'm drinking this.
(laughter)
They are literally trying fucking cake.
This is like not even real.
- Right now I feel like at the end
of this soup cleanse I'm just
not gonna have a tongue left.
I burned myself on probably every
damn soup I had and like it's 'cause
I was so hungry that like I just wanted
to pour it all down my throat.
- I didn't really feel that hungry
throughout the cleanse.
I generally felt pretty full.
It's day two of the cleanse
and there's a lot of pizza here,
there's a lot of pizza.
It was hard to say no to pizza.
It was really hard to say no to pizza.
And Shane and I cannot
indulge in any of it.
- But I feel like the beer is fine.
- Yeah, beer is a soup,
you were right about that.
- Well, it's a liquid.
I probably took this less seriously
than everyone else.
- [Voiceover] Shane, what
are you doing right now?
- I'm just having my evening soup.
I also had some cookies
and beer and pizza.
- I'm actually like
heartbroken to admit this
because I told y'all like, you know,
I wanted to commit,
nothing else, just soup,
barely water, that's it.
I had a handful of nuts.
- Look what has happened here.
This fell, it knocked my soup over.
This would not have happened if it
was a solid meal.
- My energy level by
the third day was trash.
Today is one of the biggest shoot days
of the year for me and unfortunately
it has lined up, you know,
with this soup cleanse which isn't ideal,
but that's the world I live in right now.
- My boyfriend just kept begging me
to eat something because he said
I wasn't being very nice to him.
I was kinda grumpy.
It's 9:00 at night, I'm so hungry
and I'm cooking my last soup.
- This is the final bit of
soup of the entire cleanse.
I'ma go eat til I die.
This soup cleanse went a lot better
than I thought it would.
- In terms of positive effects,
I lost two pounds.
Which was kinda nice.
- This was bearable to me 'cause I felt
like I was eating food still.
- I would definitely do
a one day cleanse again.
I feel like after the first
day I felt really good.
- I got very tired of soup.
(laughs) That's my big takeaway.
- You know, I'm still not a souphead.
I'm still not in love with soup,
but maybe I could be convinced.
(gentle upbeat music)